[Music]
uh
is anyone else kind of tired of talking
about karen's name no yes
i kind of like it one of my favorite
pages is karen's gone wild man
oh they show their titties no
karen's in the wild in the wild yeah
it's like it's like them
at the amazon no it's them being who
they are oh
like like in their element at starbucks
complaining to the manager and [ __ ] you
know or like
going to target and like i do and trying
to fight people because they
they don't want to put on a mask like
karen's in culver city and [ __ ]
yeah so in your opinion do you feel like
having a karen
in nature attitude can be beneficial
when they're on my side yeah right in
natural nature
like they're karen in in nature
conceptual wildlife i thought you meant
like karen and eaton canyon is that
beneficial
i shouldn't use in i think she's
pointing at the graffiti who's been
doing this [ __ ]
rural concept is not actually part of
the conversation i see
being a karen works when they're
actually
fighting for the rules right they're not
being a dick about it because sometimes
you need a karen
because you're not gonna say it yeah
they will like like let's say someone's
blasting [ __ ] music
at like one in the morning right like
and then most of us be like oh kids are
just gonna have parties
but then you can count on a karen to
being like it's after 10 p.m
i'm going over there telling them to
shut that [ __ ] down i'm calling the
police right
and then i'm like thank god you're there
care and i go to sleep yeah no for sure
i agree when it's situations like that
i'm like yay we need
karen's in our life but i'm just sick
and tired of talking about the karens
that are just
[ __ ] being karen's by like invading
other people's space where they don't
need to
but no i'm talking about the good
qualities of karen's
and so there's this there's this job
that has been listed
recently seeking someone hyper critical
and opinionated to write uh three
product reviews
per week while answering and maintaining
a colicarian service for this company
so they want they're looking for karen
all right yeah they're saying the right
karen will be initially contracted to
three months employment with the view
to extend if the service is popular we
are recruiting a woman to write
three honest reviews a week for our
website as well as
be the voice and authority behind our
call of care and service which we
see we will see potential customers call
for advice and recommendations on
products
call a karen that'd be fun if you you
can only be named karen to even
know oh they didn't specify like you
don't need to be named in a couple years
they're like 160 employees all named
characters
i saw this one karen video where the guy
was like do you know everyone's like
okay karen and the girl was like how do
you know my name
i was like and even the guy was like oh
[ __ ]
i was like oh it's pretty good problem
with this though so karen's i think they
are hyper critical which is good
but they all have bad taste so i don't
know if i would want a
karen recommending me something oh like
with the caring that's subjective though
because if you're a fellow karen
that taste is perfect for you that's
true right look at their hairdos
and they might be the biggest buyers of
america yeah they're gonna recommend
like the worst salons the worst cup the
worst coffee place the worst shoes the
worst cars well maybe it might work in
our favor we're like we stay away from
those
i feel like there's different levels
though like martial arts
like what we're witnessing maybe are
like
the green belts of karen there's gotta
be a black belt of karen that doesn't
exist
i haven't even seen that though we just
totally skipped brown and red but yeah
because i'm like isn't there a brown and
a white
and a white's at the bottom isn't the
black belt like hillary clinton
that's what i'm thinking you said hello
clint dude no no
no no no i just said wipeouts at the
bottom now like i was like whoa that's
weird
but i don't think hillary clinton is she
karen isn't she the ultimate karen no
karen zilla no oh zilla
i'm not proud of her either but because
she doesn't do with karen stuff
yeah she she plays a different game she
plays what is her game then
what does she do kids i don't know
we don't know yet but that's the
conspiracy that's a conspiracy that's
the
the clintons and kids yeah they're
inspiracy yeah
the karen too
i mean i feel like there's been a few or
maybe they're getting close well they
just go
out of their way to like there'll be
kids at a skate park and they're like
you guys are going too fast like doing
it's dangerous and they come out of
their way
to start harassing them or they'll be
kids angrily too yeah
and like start attacking them yeah i saw
this one video recently where it was
like
a karen basically like she was getting
hella mad because these kids were like
skating i was like getting
started to get late um and she was like
basically when you guys hang around here
start some
drugs and all this stuff and then it
just gets bad and then basically
starts like literally just starts
kicking these kids what the what she was
pushing this kid and saw the kid dumb
water on her but after
they were like she was shoving them and
then she starts literally just like
throwing like and they look like pretty
good cakes i was like she looks like she
took martial arts is she a black hair in
there i don't know
gearing up and like twisting your hips
everything all day and then luckily
another
girl jumped in and like pushed over the
other carrot yeah no like a brown belt
uh a a karen on our side
we gotta have a different name for a
karen that actually
like is good karen carol holly carol
carol yeah is there a difference like
karen no carol does sound sweeter and
like nicer
right carol yeah and she's always just
seeing
carol can i speak to you your manager
like good
good good compliment your manager yeah
for
campbell's like good job i was like can
i talk to the manager i'd like to say
that today was so awesome great customer
service
you know what i'd like to say that the
sandwich was compliments to the chef
i i've never i grew up seeing a lot of
cairns and interacting with karen's but
i
ha i can't say that i've actually even
interacted with the karen in like the
last five years
of my life really do you guys interact
with karen's like pretty often like to
find interact we used to live with one
uh or like live across from one in our
apartment but they were gonna say
is your dad the carinate oh no no no oh
my dad can be a karen he's a
he is a kid that's what i was thinking
of yeah he's that he's so funny
these are pretty intense karen yeah
don't i want to cross this path like i'm
not in the path
of like if karen is like spraying her
firepower
i've never been caught in the middle of
it uh for a while
and i don't even think i've just seen
karen in action that much i've seen like
the maybe the white both cairns here and
there
uh and i've seen like the good cairns
were like the carols
the carols yeah where that's like
everyone's waiting for their food and
then you see the kids in the back just
on their phones or talking and not
cooking
what and then like see like you're out
really [ __ ] of the
yeah the kids yeah they're like chatting
and they're like there's hell people
just waiting
um so they'll be the ones that be like
this isn't right and we're like
yeah also too i think people don't know
you can
uh disarm a karen too
so like i see like if i go to the
because we live in a neighborhood where
there's potentially very many
karens and their neighborhoods usually
yeah and then so like
when you go to the supermarket i do see
a bunch of like karen look alikes
walking robo karen's clones so like for
me i'm like
because i know i'm the minority in this
city it's up to me
to defuse any type of tension
because they're probably like what's
this [ __ ] weird like slatted eye
alien doing right
so if i go in the grocery store if i
ever lock guys with a cairn i'm always
like
like this and i can totally see them
going
yeah you're like i'm safe
and [ __ ] like judging the world you can
like just by saying hi you disarm them
and then she's like
i like that guy goes around and like you
go around you kind of disarm a lot
that's so true i do the same thing too
because after moving out of uh like the
monterey park alhambra area like
here like you don't really need to turn
that on because you're surrounded by
other minorities and
minorities just don't make good care but
when you're in a white house people [ __ ]
about anything
yeah but when you're in a white
neighborhood yeah it's a different game
and
i've had to like exercise that part of
my brain a little bit more you grew up
around that and i grew up like
in texas like i was surrounded by like a
lot of white people and like
you're just constantly needing to kind
of like that's your white people game
and i'm gonna play your game
what's the difference do you did you
observe because you grew up that was
what your your normal was yeah i didn't
i never lived amongst one the game is to
be as
extremely polite as possible in any case
whether you're mad or if you're happy
it's just you got to be polite and you
gotta
if you're mad you polite your way into
and everyone else is playing the same
game or is it is it the game like
[ __ ] yeah is it the game that you
have to play as the
model minority [ __ ] it is political
huh right because when you get mad you
like
excuse me yeah it's like that kind of
[ __ ] yeah it's just it's weird it's it's
not
you don't you don't just go like meet me
in the parking lot you know it's like
it's different i don't know i can't
it's just like after you yeah
which space when the hands go on the
hips you know it's [ __ ] business dude
that's sorry yes explain yourself please
i'm listening because i go i go jogging
a lot
and so i'm always out in the city and
like if you're not used to seeing like
another minority
or or even like asian person or whatever
i don't know they could go i don't know
they could see me and go i don't know
what this guy stereotype is this guy a
thief or is he a smart guy
i don't know so everyone just kind of
has their guards up yeah we're so like
uh
brainwashed by the media too whether we
like it or not and so like there's like
always that narrative in our minds of
like you know i don't want to be viewed
as like
that one asian you know or that one
minority so it's like
there's like a game that you play with
yourself and i don't know how healthy
you break the ice yeah if you just break
the ice then they're just like
it almost goes as if like they go oh
[ __ ] doesn't even matter if this guy's
asian or not he's just the
he's just being uh friendly to me yeah
yeah but i also feel like it should be
their job to not be racist or judgmental
that's true that's true that's true but
i don't know if it's even a conscious
thing
of them of theirs to even yeah but it's
like you're trying to be a racist but
i think in this time it goes both ways
because it's like obviously you kind of
want to show to everyone that you're
just nice right like
i don't in my neighborhood it's
predominantly white too
and just it's it's white and asian but i
never felt the need to like
have to prove myself for that people say
hi to me like i'll be in my garage
and then they'll come over i mean
they'll walk by i'd be like hey yeah
how's it going
you know then they'll they'll they'll
sit down whenever i see like
a neighbor i always say hi yeah like
i'll say hi and stuff but then
um people make the approach or whatever
i
we lock guys or whatever but then i am
in a more bigger city than you guys
too so it's i think the bigger the city
the more um people are afraid to just
saying
hi in the grocery store or whatever and
they're they also
might be more used to mixing with like
mixing with people i feel like
i'm a settler slowly moving into a
native american territory
so it's my job to go i come here in
peace
i come in that's all the settlers did
you guys
we feel like the culture is
there already yeah and then i'm new to
you guys so i'm like
i come in peace no i'm not going to blow
my boogers on the sidewalk
i'm not going to you feel like you're
working against the the fob
stereotypes yeah so like that's why i
feel like i gotta
be nice with everyone i feel like just
be yourself they'll see that too
and then whenever they judge myself is
peeing on my wall though
yeah dude if everyone was themselves
so you're lying to people is what you're
saying oh i said my my wall not your
wall
because i was in um i was in mexican
beverly hills and then because you said
mexican beverly hills yeah where's that
whittier that's friendly
because it's it's a nice neighborhood
but all my neighbors are mexican so it's
mexican beverly hills you know
i mean chinese beverly hills is arcadia
so like oh yeah
so then when i when i moved in um it was
a different
culture like it's a different like
feeling you know and they're not like
they're more like mexican-american so
they're more like
california yeah californian and they are
i don't know mexican-ish you know like
like they're just hella
uh just different you know it's not the
kind of mexicans i grew up
like you know who'd you grow up with
like people that just came from mexico
that or just chicano or like whatever
like
just more more hood you know
[Laughter]
yeah so i'm like say it joe moore hood
yeah i do have to watch how i say hi to
people like depending on where i'm at
you can't be like what's up oh yeah
sometimes you gotta be like hola yeah
like depending on who it is like i say
hi nicely or like if i'm like in an area
that's like say like downtown l.a
depending on how because i'm a
bald head bearded big brown guy we're
not dressed like
like i don't dress like it but like
sometimes like
that's very disarming but like when i
say hi to people i don't do
this i do the head down because i feel
like the head down is more like oh
what's up
like i'm what i didn't even know it was
a thing it is more like
yeah this is like that's how i grew up
as like you lower your head for respect
that's how dogs do it why don't you just
do this
dogs lower their heads well i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna say when i see a uh
like a guy i'm not gonna be like
you know like that's what i do like
every day that's how you disarm people
though for sure
yeah yeah that's because you don't
expect i've never seen anyone look at me
and go like this
really i'm like but if i see somebody
all the time
i think guy communication is different
from girl though yeah what i'm
talking about like my culture or like
the the people the people that i grew up
with not necessarily mexicans don't do
that though
i've never seen them go like like like
what's up but that's that's how i know
it's disarming because then for them
they're like oh like what's up they do
it back
but if i do this and they're like what
so i'm like oh
it does make sense i'm just mind blown
because i had never seen anyone do that
you should try like
like do that i've never seen them do
that
night of the roxbury throw them off just
start [ __ ] twitching
but i'm friendly [ __ ] what what
what no actually this this is something
this is like go outside you wanna go
outside
oh oh [ __ ] it is the wink with it oh we
could
wink is actually a lot more fun when
you're an adult has anybody been walking
a lot lately i wink at
huh when i talk to people yeah that's
stupid you go to my pep boys and like
thank you for the oil change
[Laughter]
thank you for the oil change
[Music]
so